وداعا بالنسبة لي مثل البندقية بالطريقة
التي تشكلت بها البندقية ، اعتقد الناس أنها
لن تحدث أبدًا
من على الماء ، كانت فكرة مجنونة
من كان مثل الإرهاق المائي لكنها
كانت استراتيجية كانت تتعلق بميناء
وعن نوع من  العلاقة مع آسيا
وجنوب إفريقيا وأعتقد أن دبي
أصبحت هذا النوع من نسخة القرن الحادي والعشرين
من البندقية ومثل البندقية ، فهي
حقًا مدينة هجينة وكل أنواع السيارات الهجينة
تستغرق وقتًا لتأتي إلى المنطقة ، وأعتقد
أن دبي تبدو لها جذور ذلك من
أجل  أنا وهو ما يثير فضول بالنسبة
لي عندما تنظر إليه الآن يمكنك أن
ترى أن التصميم الذي أقوم به الآن قد
أسس أسس المدينة ،
فقد أسس عظام
شبكة النمو التي يمكن أن تحدث
بطريقة تشبه تقريبًا  الهيكل
العظمي والعضلات مصنوعة ، والآن يجب
أن يكون هناك أشياء روحية مثل معرض التصميم
هو بدايات كهرباء
الروح التي كانت مهمة حقًا لأن
الروح حقًا هي التي تجعل الأماكن تتمتع
بالسحر.  هذا يجعلك أحيانًا
تجعل شيئًا
مرتبًا جدًا ثم عليك أن تضع
القليل من الفوضى للسماح ببعض
الاحتكاك للسماح ببعض الاحتكاك لأن هذه
الأشياء تخلق تأثيرات إبداعية
تخلق اضطرابات رائعة حقًا ولكن
تحسينات أعتقد أنها ظاهرة
دبي  في الوقت الحالي ، ليس من الطبيعي أن
تكون أبنيتها الأيقونية هي مبانيها ولكن في
ظواهر تخطيط المدن والتخطيط الحضري ، فإن
هذا هو الرمز ، إنه شيء
لم يسبق رؤيته
في العالم ، وهو
شيء ستعرفه بطريقة سحرية لتزرع
فيه.  الآن الفرصة
مع هذا النوع من حالة التخطيط الرئيسي الأيقوني
لإنشاء جواهر حقيقية
[موسيقى]